Logan Paul's YouTube red show got revived
Why are people so mad over the grey avatar guy?
And is Betterhelp a scam?
This and much more. I'm Gloria Borger, and you're watching Pew News.
Long shelved Logan Paul movie sequel launches today on YouTube premium
Hoooorayy
*He's excited in Japanese
I've been looking forward to The Thinning 2.
I wonder what's gonna happen, is he gonna get thinner?
Eeh, so a lot of people, eeh
at least in my Twitter feed, or anyone mentioning PewDiePie,
kind of pointed out the hypocrisy in this, if you guys remember,
Logan Paul's movie got canceled or put on hold,
as a reaction from YouTube, after he showed the dead body in the forest of Japan.
So people are saying: "Well you brought back his show,
then you need to bring back Scare PewDiePie."
"PewDiePie did a dumb edgy joke and got his show cancelled,
Logan filmed then a real dead body and got his YouTube show a sequel."
"If we are gonna release Logan Paul's YouTube Red show, then where the heck is
Scare PewDiePie season 2?"
"And following this news, as far as my personal take away, I feel like a ton of people are expecting me to
just rip into YouTube and Logan Paul, but I really don't know how to feel anymore.
I mean personally I'm more interested in what someone like PewDiePie feels about this...
WHERE IS SCARE PEWDIEPIE SEASON 2?
...losing his YouTube Red series,
which on that note as of recording of this video, I haven't seen Felix comment publicly about thi...
BRING BACK SCARE PEWDIEPIE Season... *laugh*
Okay, well if YouTube is gonna do this, where is season 2 of Scare PewDiePie?"
Sorry, what do I think? oeh, well,
I'm just Gloria Borger.
Pewdiepie is not gonna make a response. Okay?
But me, Gloria Borger! Wait... Who am i?
Poppy Harlow! *Pop*
Gloria quit, I forgot, -is gonna give my response.
If you guys remember, YouTube put Logan Paul's show on hold
ten days after the Controversy.
It took youtube ten days to come up with this assessment that, well
we're probably gonna have to cancel his show, cause otherwise we look like a bunch of fools,
cause we canceled PewDiePie's show like that.
I mean, I was asleep when they cancelled my show. I, I was... *Laugh*
It cancelled just as the news broke. That was there, that was no question about it
It just, eh, it took nowhere hesitation on that one.
But with the, with Logan Paul's show it was like
Ten days after, and, it's on hold. So it was uncertain whether it would come out or not.
Eh, It was due to be released this year.
So, I think it's only natural that you have a lot of people saying:
"Just found out that YouTube is moving forward with the second season of Logan Paul's
YouTube premium series, ten month after the suicide forest video,
so we can assume PewDiePie will be getting season 2 of his series release as well?"
I haven't seen any indication of, of that Happening whatsoever.
I've asked about it.
I don't know. Maybe this opens up for new discussions, but
it's kind of amazing how a billion-dollar company
can be so inept at leadership.
If you want to be taken seriously, you need to apply the same rules for everyone.
You can't just nitpick, eh, whatever you want, then you just look like an idiot,
and, eh, people will undoubtedly be upset, and I think that's what's happening here
So, with or without controversy,
The Thinning was coming out this year, no matter what.
It was due to be released this year, and it got released this year.
So, whatever the controversy was involved had no effect.
I mean,
what did it change? did it get delayed a month? or two months? what, what's.
There's no effect there whatsoever
Scare PewDiePie was finished. We finished shooting it. It's ready. It needs to be edited,
but that's it.
YouTube made a response to the fact that they released the show 'The Thinning',
Logan Paul's show,
saying that: "The entire cast and crew worked extremely hard to complete this film last year"
I think this is a good point because, eh, Scare PewDiePie,
we didn't work hard. Let's get real here *Laugh*
But anyway:
"In fairness to all of them, and the fans, who have been asking for the sequel, we decided to release
The Thinning: [the] New World Order."
"iN fAiRnEsS"
"IN FAIRNESS"
Thank you YouTube for your fairness *Laughing*
So, eh, apparently yeah, Scare PewDiePie, we didn't work hard and, eeeh,
Ah, if, eh, that our fans have not been asking for it whatsoever, so I believe this fairness.
But then again, they're not wrong. It, it isn't fair. I mean,
this is why when Logan Paul's controversy broke, despite me, clearly, I don't like him,
I said, I don't think his show should be canceled, and I meant that because,
you know, punish Logan for what he did, and punish me for my mistakes,
But to punish everyone involved on this project, I mean, these parts are so massive. It just doesn't make sense.
It just isn't fair to everyone else involved. I do understand that
I do understand that, there is a difference between Logan's project, eh, called 'The Thinning',
it's not "Logan Paul The Thinning", you know, eh,
here It's my show; it's PewDiePie, so maybe that's why they reacted to it differently
Maybe that's why they're doing this, ah, different treatment.
Maybe it's because I joked about jews and that's some more sensitive topics then, uh,
Topic then showing a dead body, Bros; Someone making suicide. I think that's,
probably,
what some people think at least.
I think maybe YouTube reacted a bit hast- hastingly...
Is that a word?
"Hastily"
A bit too quickly when deciding to cancel Scare PewDiePie, eh,
it was their most successful YouTube show, as far as I know.
I personally believe in the YouTube red program. It's been criticized so much, but,
it's a great idea. I really do think, eh, it has a lot of potential.
I don't think they realized, that if they did this to me,
they're gonna have to do it to everyone else,
because they clearly don't want to do that, eh, obviously they didn't.
Logan clearly got a different treatment here. I think that's pretty safe to say.
To be honest, good for him. I'm happy for him.
I stand by what I said, I don't think his show should have been canceled,
and, eh, I'm glad it got released.
Eeh, It is disappointing from my perspective, seeing that, I got different treatment.
It's kind of annoying. I think YouTube is sitting in the same boat, you know,
I'm happy that Logan's got released, but I'm unhappy that mine didn't,
and I'm sure YouTube feels the same way in a sense; I don't know.
MOVING ON!
*Pop*
What do you guys think, actually? Let me know.
BetterHelp *clap* *clap*
Meme Review. BetterHelp. If you guys checked out my video on Better Help.
Thank you guys for all the amazing support on that video,
honestly, I got some of the nicest comments I've ever gotten on a video
I, It was the most stressful video I've ever uploaded, you know,
I, I went so... I thought it was like not a big deal, you know, I can do this, but
it was stressful, I'm not gonna lie.
I, I didn't think it would be. But regardless,
basically to run it down quickly: BetterHelp is an online therapy service.
It had a lot of questionable things with it.
I pointed those out, and the fact that youtubers were paid per person signing up to this service,
To me, uh, was deeply concerning.
"Per person that they get to sign up for better help,
$200, that's a lot of money.
Just get a thousand people signing up, you just made $200,000.
Ever since that video, Better Help has removed all their video testimonies from their website,
which I thought was interesting.
I don't think it really matters.
There was this whole thing about 'Julian says', which was clearly just a guy hired to say the testimony.
"You need'nt stay alone."
Jesus
(Felix impersonating Julian) "You need'nt stay alone."
"Julian says that BetterHelp.com is a reliable online platform to receive their...
*Random Julian appears*
To communicate with a licensed psychologist from home than at an office."
"The center button also has an answer. In..."
So people found,
'Julian's' or 'Julian says' or 'Robspence' fiber page, where he does testimonials.
Big props to rob because he, eh, he had a great approach to it. I saw his response.
"Actually, you know, I haven't really done anything wrong here.
Yeah, it's embarrassing and I agree. I do have a really creepy smile at the end." *Multiple laughs*
So better help made a response to all these allegations, and, eh,
They made it the same day I recorded my video. That's why I, eh, Never got a chance to talk about it.
So it seems only fair that I talk about it now,
Especially the, eh, due to the fact that they've been tweeting this frantically to anyone
caught commenting about better help on Twitter:
"Hey, you may be misinformed. Hey you maybe misinformed, read this.", so let's read it.
Let's go through it, uum.
It was written by the CEO of BetterHelp on Medium, and I think he went to Reddit as well.
"Hi, I'm BetterHelp's founder. Here are my thoughts."
They basically go on to say how great BetterHelp is, how
very few companies can truly say that their value is enable, is to enable a better life,
and, eh, just that they're doing a great job, basically.
Strangely enough, they are funny enough, I guess.
They bring up the drama between Keemstar and, eh, Phil:
"Virtual fight with another youtuber host, who has several million followers"
sort of pivoting it as, this was all a reaction to drama,
people just wanting drama, and, uh,
that's what cause for it.
I didn't mention anything about Phil in my video, because I didn't want it to be about drama,
I wanted to just be clear, what my criticism of BetterHelp was.
They also go on to say, that they have a long process of verifying their therapist, and they can assure that, eh,
their therapist are legit.
But their terms of service clearly stated completely differently,
and they basically said, it was up to you to determine, whether you were talking to an actual therapist or not.
This one says that they don't guarantee the verification of the: "skills, degrees, qualifications,
certification, credentials, competence or background of any counselor."
With BetterHelp you'll be talking to professionals,
just be aware that it's: "your responsibility" to detemine whether they are or not.
Uh, you could be talking to some guy in Ur- Ukraine, sending you sad smiley emojis.
They also bring up all these conspiracy theory allegations,
which I understand, there weren't a lot of weird conspiracies going on,
while trying to uncover BetterHelp. I didn't bring up any of it,
I mean,
the biggest one was probably
the Julian says one, which I brought up because it was funny.
Then they finished off with the ultimate level of smugness,
saying that: "Ironically, over this interesting week, we've had a record number of new members who signed up."
Congratulations BetterHelp. So they basically don't care.
So what they didn't adress, was that, why do they market that they cost $65 per week,
but they still charge you monthly.
This is what it says, when they ask you to enter your credit card information:
"Free trial, try the service seven days no risk." Look, $0.
If you're one of the companies that can truly say that their value is to enable a better life,
then why do you need to use these sort of learning business methods,
to get people to sign up for your subscription?
Why can't you just say the amount that you will charge you?
Why can't you just be honest and clear about that? Why this level of deception involved?
Second, why do you mark it, still, here, as a replacement for in-office counseling?
While in your Terms of Service, you still say, that you are: "not a complete substitute for face-to-face examination."
Look how much money you save by not using our therapist.
I've been getting a ton of messages from actual therapists, or people that have gone through therapy,
who said that this sort of idea of online therapy is ridiculous.
You need to properly sit down face-to-face with a person,
to get the job done, to get to the core of the issue
Obviously, I'm not an expert.
Why are people saying that they got diagnosed from BetterHelp?
They also replied to the bad reviews on the website, saying that: "they can't vouch for their authenticity."
Funnily enough, that's what I said in my video. I can't vouch,
that the bad reviews aren't authentic.
But then you can either vouch for the positive ones.
It's such an non-argument
So, I think what a lot of people wanted to know, is BetterHelp a scam?
And I watched this video from YouTuber Law,
which was really interesting.
"So with all these different issues, and believe me, there are more and more provisions,
that I just don't want to go through, that are just funny and make no sense and are indicative of the fact that
somebody did a cut-and-paste over, off of other people's websites.
Why do I say it's not a scam?
It's because I've dealt with so many of these kind of platforms, and I tell you, they make no money here.
These platform makes pennies on the dollars, and as a result,
if you want to scam people, this is like the worst business model, through which to scam people.
There are far far better ways to do it online."
Basically explaining that their terms of service is extremely poorly written.
They most likely just copied and pasted a lot of pieces from it,
and, eh, they probably just wanted to save money.
So, while they legally might not be a scam, they certainly have a lot of questionable things
about them.
To be honest, I think it's entirely possible that they have good intentions, uuh,
but the difference between their, what they're saying in their Terms of Service, and
how they market it, to me shows, that they're very irresponsible at least, and that
it shows me as well, where their focus is.
They've clearly spent a lot more time, on how to market and sell their product.
I'm not personally against a company like BetterHelp existing,
even if I'm skeptic whether online therapy works or not, or if it's the best way.
I understand that that's a service that a lot of people can actually benefit from,
but clearly it's not positive for everyone,
and combine that with the fact that youtubers are promoting this, getting $200 per sign up,
with the topic of mental help, to me, that's very very concerning.
Maybe that's a personal thing, cause I hate referrals.
I understand that they are a common practice in, uh,
in business and even therapy, but
to compare that with YouTubers telling their fans to sign up; I think it's completely different,
because they have licenses and policies.
$200 pr. fan with mental health issues, or struggling with mental health.
I don't like it.
But like I said in the video, at the same time, I don't think these YouTubers knew what they were promoting.
I don't think they looked into it too deeply.
I even had youtubers that I showed in my video thanking me for showing the issues with BetterHelp,
and, uuh, it was nice to see that reaction.
Now, I also want to mention that,
I felt like it was important, that I showed how youtubers promoted this service.
It was a big part of the whole thing for me.
"And he goes through the Terms of Service, and he points out a lot of questionable things, which is fine,
and he doesn't like the service, and he raises good points about it,
but the way that he presented my involvement in it,
I thought was a little misleading, and a little out of context,
and it made it look like,
I was way more involved with this company then I was."
"It was, it was gotten so bad that it was basically either:
stop making videos or disappear."
"Also this video is sponsored by better help. More information about that at the end of this video."
So basically, I, I agree. I cut this very poorly.
I thought it was clear, that this was Bobby's video and not Ethan's video.
But even then, I wanted to be clear. My point was not to drag these YouTubers.
I'm sure Bobby had good intentions while pushing this service,
cause if you think you are promoting a service that is helping other fans, and you get paid at the same time,
I mean,
that seems pretty win-win to me, but that's clearly not necessarily the case.
But I felt like, it was necessary to show, uh, these youtubers, how they was promoted in the video,
but that clearly led to a lot of drama and controversies, and I think this is a good lesson for everyone;
look more carefully Into what you're promoting to your fans,
especially if you are paid per person using that product.
That being said,
check out my new merch everybody! That's right, meme review!
*Clap, Clap*
YouTube's favorite merch, actually it's PewDiePie's merch.
I'm just Gloria Borger, *Pop*
I mean Pappy Harlew, showing this merch.
It's only available for four more days, I mean, three more days.
NEXT *Clap* NEWS *Clap*
*Pop*
BBC trending: Why has Twitter banned 1500 accounts? And what are NPCs?
You've probably seen this meme. It's been practically everywhere.
I've been debating: do I show this on Pew News or Meme Review?
What are, where is, where does this is belong?
I love how Pew News and Meme Review is just been, never been closer together.
Me and PewDiePie have been discussing this, but I feel very passionate about this story.
This started from a post online saying that: "I have a theory,
that there are only a fixed quantity of souls on planet Earth, that cycles continuously through reincarnation.
However, since the human growth rate is so severe,
the soulless extra walking flesh piles around us as NPC's, or ultimate Normas.
People who are autonomously follow group things and social trends in order to appear convincingly human.
I called these people NPC's because when you talk to them, they just say the same shit every time:
'Trump is bad', 'Just be yourself', 'Sports ball', 'The new Adele song omg'.
If you get a discussion with them, it's always the same buzzwords."
I love this meme because from a spiritual or philosophical standpoint, it makes 100 percent sense,
okay,
you have all these feel-good quotes saying like:
Oh, there's just as many stars in the galaxy, as there are, people that have lived on earth in our galaxy.
Well, what about the new ones then? Huh? We got more and more people living.
NPC theory proven. Thank you very much. We are Pew News here.
We report on the facts. The facts, the truth and nothing but the truth.
Hello, I am a comedian on television. If you disagree with my politics, you must be mentally ill.
Diversity is our strength!
So a lot of people that had a problem with this meme, which it just makes it even funnier,
the fact that people actually give a damn about this stupid meme.
It blows my mind.
I think that's the main reason why it's funny.
If no one cared about this meme, it wouldn't be funny, but people are saying that it's dehumanizing.
Chad and PC: only watches Game of Thrones, has seen every Marvel movie and can't wait for the next Star Wars.
WAKE UP 'sheeple' (people), I've been telling this for years.
MARVEL MOVIES are TRASH! *Laugh*
You like MARVEL? yoUR NEIGHBOR IS TRASH! *Laugh*
Unfortunately, this, this golden meme. This meme dipped in gold, has gotten tainted by politics.
Which of Donald Trump core values do you support?
You have left and right basically saying: 'you're an MPC', or 'you're an MPC'.
INSULT.XE, so Trump, hahaha.
The New York Times' reporting on this: "What is the [the] NPC, the Pro-Trump Internet's favorite insult?"
Jesus Christ.
Are these Russian BOTS?
PROBerbly NOT.
Proberbly.
2018 everybody. The beams are, they're in a strange place, I gotta say.
The New York Times even asking themselves: "Aren't you giving these trolls (the) attention
they're seeking by writing about them in the New York Times?"
"Yes,"
You are 100 procent giving these people more power by talking about it,
but they can't help themselves. They just can't help themselves.
It's so satisfying to symbolize something as an evil,
eeeh,
evil thing.
To most people, it's just a meme. No one thinks about it as any further.
So rest in peace NBC meme. This one you can't blame on Meme Review, okay?
I had nothing to, I mean, I never have anything...
Last but not least, Shane Dawson finished his series on Jake Paul.
I'm only bring this up because I criticized that one episode.
Otherwise, I thought it was a great series. I really really enjoyed it, I have a lot of respect for Shane.
*Jake Paul saying "like", way to many times for me to write*
They're really pushing the boundary on, uh,
on videos in general. I think it's, eh, it's really impressive and inspiring what they're doing, eeh,
so, that's why for this week's "Shout Out Week", I'm shouting out Shane.
He clearly needs a shout out from me guys.
So, uh, I don't know if you guys have heard of a Shane Dawson...
You probably never heard of him.
Small YouTuber. Needs a shout out.
No, but for real, I, I, I meant what I said, and especially with me criticizing, eh, one of the episodes.
Just cuz I criticize something, doesn't mean I hate that person, or, eh,
have some personal vendetta with it or whatever.
To me, It's very different. And I think the same thing goes with, uh, the BetteHelp stuff
you know, I may criticize YouTubers or stuff in general, but I don't personally hate someone or whatever.
I ree-, I especialy enjoyed the last episode by the way, uh,
hearing Jake speak so, uh, eloquently, uuh,
it was a, it was wonderful to hear Jake...
"Like, i got just like,
like,
like even with Erica, I like"
Leave like if you enjoyed this video,
I appreciate all the support. Consider becoming a sponsor, if you want to, and buy the merch,
that's probably the best way to support this channel.
Uuh, It's really late, I gotta go. Goodbye, god- just goodbye.
*Pop*